[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'europe
hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne cette semaine
émission spéciale est invitée spéciale
sandro gaudi ministre italien des
affaires européennes à leur économie
défense climat break site
nous allons revenir quelques semaines
après l'accession au pouvoir des manuels
macron sur les enjeux de cette europe à
réformer à refonder après le sommet de
l'otan et le g7 emmanuel macron dans ses
habits neufs de président de la
république recevait ce lundi vladimir
poutine
sous les ors du château de versailles
une visite haute en symboles
on écoute sur la syrie
j'ai rappelé quelles étaient nos
priorités et je crois que nous pouvons
sur cette voie travailler ensemble en
tout cas c'est mon souhait dans les
prochaines semaines vous avez posé la
question par rapport à des sanctions
contre la russie à quel point est-ce que
ces sanctions et des normalisée et la
crise au sud ouest en ukraine ils ne
peuvent pas ils ne sont pas capables de
l'aider à trouver la solution à cette
crise
bonjour se rendre à gaudi bonjour vous
êtes secrétaire d'état italien aux
affaires européennes vous avez sans
doute suivi la visite de vladimir
poutine à emmanuel macron ce lundi à
versailles
diriez vous que la russie est de retour
en fait dans le concert des nations
car on a besoin d'elle je ne sais pas si
c'est la fin d'une phase dans laquelle
sans doute les rapports entre nous et la
russie était très tendue nous pensons
que c'est nécessaire des maîtres à côté
de la ferme et t on vers la russie sur
la question des accords de misc inscrits
sur la liste du cren un véritable
dialogue un dialogue active et comme les
précédents macron a dit un dialogue
exigeant
c'est fondamental parce que de toute
façon la russie est un acteur
incontournable se lasser internationale
et notamment aux étals en syrie
notamment en syrie au moyen-orient pour
nous aussi en libye et dans la
méditerranée
donc il est nécessaire d'avoir un
dialogue avec la russie mais là aussi
comme emmanuel macron ali les dialogues
doit être exigeant et personnellement et
nous avons beaucoup apprécié les fêtes
qui macron et discuter avec poutine
aussi des questions de ses droits
fondamentaux des droits de la communauté
lgbt des droits c'est c'est la bonne
façon d'avoir une diplomatie cohérente
et réaliste avec un interlocuteur comme
comme moscou c'est un changement de
doctrine par rapport à ce que prônait
françois hollande c'est à dire que par
exemple dans la même veine vous seriez
favorables à une levée des sanctions
vis-à-vis de moscou
l'italie a toujours tout d'abord dit la
question des sanctions ce n'est pas une
question automatique à l'essai au aux
ambassadeurs a laissé diplomate
c'est une question éminemment politique
et donc on a obtenu déjà grâce à
l'action des matériaux insee à l'époque
de son gouvernement que les
renouvellements des sanctions soient pas
pris défenseur automatique mais soit les
fruits d'in
dans d'un dialogue et d'une vérification
au plus haut niveau politique et celui
du conseil européen des chefs d'état de
gouvernement et nous pensons que la même
chose doit se faire alors que on
s'approche à la fin de la nouvelle phase
des sanctions
on en juin je crois que nous pensons que
11 juin les chefs d'état y devant le
monde doit faire une évaluation sur la
mise en oeuvre des accords de misc ces
accords qui concerne l'ukraine une
évaluation sur la nécessité d renouveler
les actions ou pas du point de vue
italien les sanctions ne sont pas
empêchés d'avoir un dialogue avec
poutine le président du conseil italien
john taylor n'était associe la semaine
dernière et il ya eu toute une série
d'engagements d'accord qu'on a qu'on a
fait avec la russie de poutine et
aujourd'hui les sanctions n'empêche pas
un dialogue avec la russie sur d'autres
questions et la visite à versailles de
vladimir poutine
des montres qui aujourd'hui les
sanctionne n'empêche pas ça les cinq
sens sont liées à la mise en oeuvre d'un
accord pour laquelle il faut faire des
pas en avant
du côté des russes et deux côtés les os
crânien dimanche dernier à munich
angela merkel a fait une déclaration
assez tonitruante donc à la fin du g7 à
la fin du sommet de l'otan
on les écoute
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque où nous pouvions entièrement
compter les uns sur les autres et
quasiment révolue
c'est mon expérience de ces derniers
jours nous européens devons prendre
notre destin en main c'est que notre
amitié avec les états unis avec le
royaume uni
notre bon voisinage avec la russie aussi
avec d'autres pays
cela compte mais nous devons savoir nous
devons nous battre pour notre propre
futur pour notre destin et j'aimerais
faire cela ensemble au téléphone me dit
sandro gozi est ce à dire par rapport à
ce que vient de dire en gala merkel que
les états unis et la grande bretagne ne
sont plus les partenaires de l'union
européenne nom signifie que finalement
la chancellière à arrêter des reportages
les véritables questions politiques et
nous disons dépit des années que les
europe doit être refondée doit être
profondément réformé qui est l'europe
doit être fait pour sauver l'europe il
faut la changer et qu'il faut corriger
toutes les séries d'erreur ou combler et
ou des séries d'un liquide des lacunes
et d'absence de l'union européenne dans
la dernière décennie
de ce point de vue si la chance est liée
à vos véritablement s'engager soit une
réponde à sion politique de l'europe
nous sommes tout à fait favorables et
nous voulons que c'est la liant à matteo
renzi de ventilo ni depuis longtemps il
ya une nouvelle phase qui s'ouvre
finalement il se dessine en europe un
contexte politique que nous avons
souhaité des neveux dépit 2014 et qui
met semble avoir une manuelle macron un
protagoniste certains et une allemagne
qui me semblent commencent à prendre
conscience et on peut plus reporter
qu'on a trop reporter les décisions
fondamentales et quant à toutes les
séries décisions fondamentales des
constructions de l'union politique et
construction aussi l'union politique qui
s'affirment plus cela c'est
international qui est tout à fait
nécessaire et sur lesquels nous sont en
temps qui t'a dit prêt à travailler avec
perly avec paris avec bernard avec tous
les autres pays qui sont qui partagent
une autre analyse et qui partagent tous
une autre volonté de refonder
politiquement l'europe et elle a refondé
politiquement l'europe c'est quoi la
priorité c'est d'abord la zone euro
c'est faire en sorte d'avoir comme le
porte emmanuel macron une zone euro
approfondie plus intégré une zone euro
plus politique avec un budget spécifique
pourquoi pas donc un parlement un
ministre permanent de l'économie de la
zone euro sont toutes les propositions
que nous avons faites et qui vendent
après nous de la bonne direction
nous pensons que la zone euro elle n'est
pas soutenable dans l'état où elles se
trouvent
il faut tout d'abord
développer une véritable politique
d'investissement dans la zone euro donc
il faut donner des ressources
les nouvelles ressources à lomé avec
quel budget faire de la personne n'y a
pas raison cette proposition de
transformer les mécanisme européen de
stabilité dans un fonds qui d'après nous
pour être en fonds pour les
investissements
donc on a déjà un instrument qu'on
pourrait développer et nous devons
donner cet instrument si on donne un
instrument pour faire une véritable
politique économie d'investissement
alors on peut discuter aussi d'un
ministre et ses ministres il doit pas
être tout simplement travailler dans les
copinages avec ses pairs les autres
ministres de l'économie des finances
noiret dans les caisses de leur groupe
il va répondre les regroupent c'est un
protocole annexé au traité ce même pas
une institution et en tant que protocole
annexé au traité aujourd'hui lettres des
pouvoirs sans contrôle et aux vrais
problèmes en grèce d'ailleurs il faut
mettre qui passe dans ta yo démocratique
donc les nouveaux ministres
avec un budget une capacité pour les uns
des ressources pour les investissements
doit être doit agir sous contrôle
démocratique du parlement européen et
des parlements nationaux et nous pensons
que ces avancées sont possibles déjà
aujourd'hui et nous a traités constants
nous sommes nous sommes convaincus que
c'est s'il est possible à 13 est
constant et donc les deux par exemple
modifier les traités comme emmanuel
macron et angela merkel ont pu le dire
lors de sa visite à berlin par exemple
vous seriez favorable oui nous sommes
favorable depuis longtemps pour nous la
révision des traités n'a jamais été un
tabou
white man macro nous a dit qu'en france
un tabou elle un tableau qui lui a
décidé d'élever très bien pour nous ne
l'a jamais été et nous sommes tout à
fait prêts à travailler au 6e révision
des traités mais révision et traiter des
mondes du temps et nous devons un
pédalier du temps parce qu'il ya des
choses qu'on peut faire sans arriverons
à les traiter et il faut les faire de
suite et les les réformes de la zone
euro dont on a parlé une bonne partie de
ces réformes
on peut les faire sans réformer les
traités ont fallait faire tout de suite
dont nous pensons qu'elles après les
élections allemandes s'ouvre une fenêtre
d'opportunité politique que nous devons
absolument saisir et après il faut aussi
pour nous mettre en oeuvre la
déclaration des roms la déclaration
qu'on a adopté les vans et mars à
l'occasion des 60 ans de traiter des
roms europe de la défense europe sociale
lui europe qui se donne une nouvelle
politique contre le terrorisme et europe
qui multiplie les opportunités pour la
jeunesse sont quatre points objectif
autour desquels nous pouvons répondre et
l'europe
là où c'est possible adam 7 là où c'est
nécessaire par un groupe des pays qui
assument des responsabilités par une
europe à deux vitesses
si c'était la nécessaire nous sont tout
à fait favorables à que ce qu'est un
groupe dynamique des pays mettront de
l'avant toujours de façon ouverte à tous
ceux qui veulent nous rejoindre et
toujours deux heures de façon inclusive
des institutions européennes il y a un
enjeu fondamental auquel l'europe est
confrontée depuis le 23 juin de l'année
dernière date à laquelle les
britanniques ont voté pour la sortie de
leur pays de l'union européenne
theresa may a déclenché donc l'article
il y a quelques semaines et à convoquer
de nouvelles élections et donc les
britanniques sont de nouveau appelés aux
urnes le 8 juin pour élire donc leurs
représentants qui vont devoir négocier
et à terme donc sortir de l'union
européenne quant à calme est donc s'est
rendu
à londres pour faire un petit tour
justement de cette campagne des
législatives et des enjeux du bric site
reportage
[Musique]
c'était il ya un an un choc
une claque pour tous les européens et
une nouvelle crise pour l'union le début
également d'une période d'incertitude
pour les marchés financiers
aujourd'hui une nouvelle étape décisive
se dessine pour le pays
le 8 juin les électeurs sont à nouveau
appelés aux urnes pour des élections
législatives et choisir le premier
ministre qui mènera les négociations
durent excite l'an dernier à douvres le
score pour quitter l'union européenne
étaient parmi les plus élevés de toute
la grande-bretagne une victoire pour le
youki un parti populiste anti
immigration et anti europe qui espère
désormais transformer l'essai et
révérons stuart piper je suis le
candidat aux législatives pour le you
keep le parti de l'indépendance du
royaume uni dans la circonscription de
ramsgate cela net
c'est très proche de 12
douvres le théâtre d'un ballet incessant
de camions est le point le plus proche
de la france en grande bretagne
à seulement 35 km du continent européen
agoda et par beau temps bien sûr vous
pouvez voir très très nettement les
côtes françaises et cela nous rappelle
combien nous sommes proches de l'europe
une proximité géographique et pourtant
pour stuart piper il n'y a aucun regret
à avoir sur le break site
le bric site est ce qu'il est cela ne
signifie pas que nous n'aimons plus nos
voisins français ou allemands ou
néerlandais et belge cela signifie
simplement que nous quittons une union
politique
nous ne nous attendons pas à rester
membres du marché commun
principalement parce que cela signifie
qu'il faudrait accepter la libre
circulation des personnes
donc nous voulons impuissante accord
commercial avec nos voisins européens
mais pas d'appartenance au marché
comment douvres devenue ville symbole
d'une grande bretagne qui tourne le dos
au reste de l'europe
sans regret c'est ici que l'artiste
banksy a décidé de peindre une imposante
fresque
cette oeuvre est apparue ici un matin
début mai donc si un mystérieux artiste
qui défraie la chronique avec des
messages anti militariste et subversif
robert guéï d'heure mi-temps do you keep
cette oeuvre n'est pas anti briques site
mais un simple symbole de la sortie de
l'union européenne elle me rend compte
qu'il s'agit d'un message très fort mais
vraiment tout dépend de là où vous vous
positionnez dans ce débat selon moi le
message c'est qu'au long terme l'union
européenne va s'arrêter que par la
direction qu'elle a prises elle est
lentement en train de s'effondrer
longue de choc du bric site a été
ressenti dans tout le pays
particulièrement à westminster et à la
city en plein coeur de londres
ici on a largement voté remain pour
rester dans l'europe l'an dernier
ibrahim de zombies et le candidat
travailliste dans cette prestigieuse
circonscriptions aujourd'hui en campagne
il est immanquablement interrogé sur le
break site
un thème qui inquiète ses électeurs je
me suis beaucoup battu pour que l'on
reste membre de l'union européenne
mais la décision a été prise par le
peuple britannique
probablement que beaucoup regrettent
leur décision de voter pour la sortie de
l'union européenne mais cela a été
décidé et nous devons accepter le
résultat désormais nous devons
travailler dur pour être certain
d'obtenir le meilleur accord sur le
break six de suite après le référendum
nous avons vu une augmentation du nombre
d'actes racistes sur les minorités et
sur les citoyens européens qui vivent au
royaume uni c'est une période très dure
pour nous tous dans le pays
à la city de londres depuis un an on
surveille avec fébrilité le cours de la
livre sterling
c'est tout l'enjeu des prochains mois
quel avenir pour cette immense entre
financier qui réalise 10 % du pib de la
grande bretagne
car avec la sortie du marché commun
certaines activités financières
pourraient être rapatriés sur le
continent avec des conséquences en
termes d'emploi certains services
financiers vont peut-être voir une
poignée de personnes s'en aller mais
alors le responsable des risques de
chacune de ces banques va-t-il partir
également son équipe partent elles aussi
bien seul coup ce qui a commencé avec un
emploi devient dix ou douze emplois la
maintenance informatique
les services de ressources humaines tout
cela ce n'était qu'un millier d'emplois
cela devient un 5000 10000 un immense
brouillard entoure toujours la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union qui à londres
on s'interroge sur le nombre d'emplois
qui pourraient quitter la ville
dans tout le pays on se demande combien
va coûter ce divorce mais aussi ce qui
va changer pour les citoyens européens
en grande bretagne tout comme pour les
britanniques vivant sur le continent
tous devront attendre pour voir cette
english fog se dissiper
sandro gozi on a vu pour une fois les
européens les 27 extrêmement unie face à
la grande bretagne
est-ce que vous pensez que cette unité
est en capacité en fait de peser sur les
négociations sur le bric site et
notamment sur ses citoyens qui vont
devoir subir que ce soit sur le
continent ou en grande-bretagne
peut-être leur changement de situation
cette unité fondamentale ne sera pas
toujours facile à tenir mais les
fondamentale la négociation c'est pas à
l'égalisation c'est à deux d'un côté le
rêve ni deux le côté l'union européenne
qui doit au quotidien négocié à travers
son négociateur michel barnier ça c'est
une condition fondamentale avec une
transparence
les négociations pour que nous puissions
aboutir
ça sera négociations difficiles cette
invitation ou pour des raisons morales
encore encore à avant que politique
juridique il est inacceptable que
non-ressortissants soit pris en otage en
réunit pendant la négociation c'est pour
cela qu'il nous disons nous devons tout
de suite régler la question des
ressortissants de l'union européenne
résidant hors mvno c'est une question
fondamentale sur une base de réciprocité
évidemment parce qu'il ya pas mal des
britanniques qui sont en france en
italie beaucoup en espagne assure
exemple et donc sur une base de la
société il faut aborder tout de suite et
les autorités avant même la facture du
divorce
c'est une priorité avant même vous dites
factuel divorce
moi j'ai dit les obligations grecques et
leur est muni c'est as a assumé et doit
respecter jusqu'au dernier jour
est ce que vous seriez prêt à offrir par
exemple la citoyenneté italienne de
manière facilitée aux britanniques qui
vivent sur notre sol est ce que ça
pourrait être une option évoquée
nous l'avions évoqué matériel a évoqué
cette option elle avait fait pour donner
un signal aussi à ses 48 et quelques
pour cent des électeurs britanniques qui
avaient voté pour rester et c'est pour
cela que j'utilise toujours les 3r pour
décrire la relation et l'attitude qu'il
faut avoir pigé vis-à-vis du réuni
regretté je regrette les choix mais
c'était un choix démocratique donc j'ai
le respect régate est respecté et
remplacés il faut remplacer la même au
chip des britanniques des l'union
européenne avec un nouveau partenariat
fort et pourquoi pas un partenaire à
fort des façons d'aider la citoyenneté
ce serait un très bon message
mais nous verrons pendant la négociation
commence à s'y déroulent comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire son de rgo dix
ans les britanniques dans le cadre de la
lutte antiterroriste on a vu encore que
sur le sol britannique a eu lieu donc
l'un des attentats les plus meurtriers
depuis 2005 sans les britanniques la
lutte antiterroriste la question de la
défense
est-ce que ça va pas être un petit peu
caduque je ferai une distinction entre
les deux les robes de la défense pour
progresser plus rapidement sans les
britanniques dans l'essence et les
britanniques sont toujours opposés à un
véritable à la véritable mise en oeuvre
d'un projet d'europe de la défense
alors maintenant notamment la france et
l'italie quand les industries de la
défense et les plus importantes d'un
continent doivent s'engager pour
construire cette europe de la défense
l'autre question c'est la coopération
des polices judiciaires des services
secrets d'une telle lutteuse pour lutter
contre théorise et pourrait faire un
travail de prévention et l'échangé
d'information musclé et efficace de ce
point de vue un des objectifs que les
usa may a indiqué pour les partenariats
à l'avenir entre union européenne romney
est justement la sécurité et nous devons
assurer sa me devons assurer une
relation forte avec les britanniques
une fois qui sert en sortie de l'union
européenne dans le domaine de la
sécurité est donc ce sera un sujet de la
négociation sur les briques site alors
le break site a montré en que la
question de la citoyenneté européenne de
se sentir européen était quand même un
des enjeux fondamentaux en europe
on a vu la montée des populismes partout
vous préfacé un ouvrage sur les trente
ans d'erasmus vous êtes donc vous même
un ancien maire à sousse diriez vous que
la
la mobilité européenne le fait de
rencontrer d'autres européens
c'est une solution pour éviter cette
montée des populismes pour moi erasmus
est le meilleur antidote contre les
populismes et les extrémismes un terreau
p1 parce que quand on vit les europe sur
sa peau des façons positif grâce à un
programme de mobilité on comprendre que
l'on peut pas vouloir détruire vouloir
sortir d'un projet qui est
multiplication des droits et des
opportunités pour tous les citoyens
européens
et c'est pour cela que deux ports sont
des étudiants qui participaient les red
bulls n'est pas suffisant et c'est pour
cela que nous avons proposé en tant que
gouvernement italien dé multiplier par
dix les ressources affectées à l'erasmus
à partir de 2020 et d'aller bien trente
ans c'était plus ou moins 4 millions d
européens qui ont participé à la tenue
dans les prochains 30 ans ils devront
être 40 millions et à savoir il faut
donner à tout le monde en augmentant les
ressources parce qu'il ya des gens
défavorisés qui ne ne peut pas se
permettre les progrès des mobilités
donné à tout le monde l'opportunité dé
vivre l'europe auprès des personnes
c'est le meilleur antidote aux préjugés
et stéréotypes et aurait tour au repli
sur des frontières nationales qui se
seraient des murs dans lesquelles nous
allons voir venir c'est d'ailleurs votre
refesse donc de l' ouvrage que vous
allez signer aux éditions la martinière
ils ont fait et rasmus vous le dites
vous avez été vous même
donc à la sorbonne quelques années 90
après la chute du mur de berlin
voilà exactement revoir des frontières
revoir des murs érigés en europe on voit
en hongrie est ce que ne s'est pas un
constat d'échec pour vous et nous devons
pas renoncer au plus grand acquis des
l'europe qui est c'est la liberté pour
résoudre la question des flux
migratoires
ce n'est pas en remettant un mur à
vintimille qui est vous les français et
nous les italiens nous aurons résolu
cette question nous devons nous demander
où sont nos frontières aujourd'hui pour
l'immigration pour lutter contre les
trafiquants d'êtres humains la frontière
entre la libye et le niger par exemple
en train libéré chat c'est ça une
frontière européen pour moi mais
dépasserait celle évidemment et par la
suite comme on a des questions ouvertes
au sud de la libye dans la lah frais de
l'afrique subsaharienne
on a évidemment un problème qui est
aggravée par le fait que la libye
aujourd'hui doit être stabilisée et qui
est source d'un prof des problèmes qui
ne sont pas seulement des problèmes
italiens sont des problèmes communs
européens semaine des problèmes globaux
c'est ça qu'on a essayé de faire passer
au g7 détermine la question migratoire
c'est une grande question globale et
nous nous les européens nous pouvons
commencer à la contrôler et à la gérer
au lieu de la subir
seulement avec des nouvelles politiques
européennes et une nouvelle relation
entre europe et afrique et pas en
construisant des murs autour de la
hongrie cette retour aux frontières
nationales ces replis nationalistes ses
tentatives débat faut il est adroit et
les droits fondamentaux qui sait
succèdent ces tentatives à l'intérieur
d'un trn notre union européenne et sont
inacceptables
est ce que nous devons et nous devons
contrer vu cette dérive parce que comme
marguerite yourcenar a écrit tout
construit un mur à mur parce que tu
penses qu'il va te défendre et après
tout découvre qu'il va impressionner et
c'est ça qu'on ne doit pas accepter en
europe
dernière question son argot dit les
premiers par des manuels macron que vous
connaissez bien sur la scène
internationale qu'est ce que vous avez à
en dire excellent honnêtement excellent
maintenant oui je connais depuis
plusieurs années j'ai parlé lui dans mon
ouvrage génération erasmus
quand il était encore ministre est peu
connu en europe et je crois que c'est un
début un excellent il a été très bon à
l'otan il a joué un rôle très important
dans les j'essaie d'état aux mines qui
était en jeu c'est très très difficile
et pour nous qui nous étions présidence
et c'était encore plus difficile mais
emmanuel macron a joué un rôle très
constructif notamment vis-à-vis de
donald trump notamment vis-à-vis dans la
trame notamment vis-à-vis de la question
du changement climatique mais aussi sur
la question des migratoires et je crois
que la façon dont il a reçu et ses
dialogues exigeons qu'il a mené avec
poutine ça va tout à fait dans la bonne
direction donc vu des rangs mais vu de
ma perspective je suis tout à fait
satisfait et du début des manuels merci
beaucoup
sandro gozi d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
alors tout de suite c'est l'heure du
checkpoint si cette semaine thomas
mignon s'est intéressé à une déclaration
d'elio di rupo anciens premiers
ministres belge et leader du parti
socialiste le checkpoint s'est tout de
suite
[Musique]
le pouvoir d'achat est l'évolution des
prix en belgique le président du parti
socialiste elio di rupo a sur ce point
vivement critiqué la politique
économique du gouvernement fédéral sur
les deux dernières années dit-il la
belgique a connu la plus forte
augmentation des prix de tous les pays
de la zone euro autrement dit on fait un
autre pays de l'eurozone n'aurait su une
inflation aussi importante ces deux
dernières années alors tout d'abord
comment les prix ont-ils évolué en
belgique
pour le savoir il faut analyser l indice
des prix à la consommation la disent
qu'ils surveillent le prix du panier de
la ménagère pour voir s'il a augmenté ou
au contraire diminué
si l'on prend les dernières données
disponibles on voit qu'un produit un
téléphone portable par exemple afficher
sort au deuxième trimestre 2015 est
passé à près de 104 euros deux ans plus
tard cela correspond tout simplement à 4
% d'augmentation
et plutôt que de comparer les résultats
entre deux trimestres comparons
l'évolution des prix entre deux années
complètes qui l'on reprend un produit
disons en aspirateurs qui faisait 100
euros en 2014
cette fois est bien en 2016 il a grimpé
à 102 euros 40
cela nous donne donc en deux années
complètes ce deuxième 4% d'inflation
mais est ce pour autant la plus forte
augmentation des prix de la zone euro
les prix ont diminué dans certains pays
notamment en espagne en grèce en
slovénie d'autres ont vu le panier de la
ménagère resté parfaitement stable
c'est le cas de l'italie et de la
lituanie et dans de nombreux autres
états membres les prix ont gonflé en
france par exemple l'augmentation a été
de 0 4% en deux ans plus importantes ont
été les hausses vécue par le portugal
avec 15% ou par malte 2%
les avec ses 2 24 % la belgique aucun la
palme de l'augmentation des prix aucun
pays de la zone euro ne fait pire ni
même aucun de l'union européenne
bref la belgique at-elle connu la plus
forte augmentation n'est plus en deux
ans c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
et voilà pour le checkpoint dos thomas
mignon c'est la fin de sa mission mais
pas de panique vous pouvez la revoir en
replay sur nos sites internet la semaine
prochaine cette âme et azir aux
commandes depuis bruxelles très belle
semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec pub